mitochondrial diseases cover a wide
range of conditions caused by genetic
mutations in the UK alone they affect
thousands mitochondria are the
powerhouses of the cell they use a
process called
oxidative phosphorylation to generate
energy but a mitochondrion is a complex
piece of machinery and a lot can go
wrong it takes around 1,500 proteins for
mitochondria to function and problems
with many of these can lead to disease
the cells nuclear DNA creates all but 13
of these proteins the rest are coded for
by the DNA in the mitochondria
themselves and mutations in either can
cause problems a cell has just one
nucleus and many mitochondria all the
cell's mitochondria contain their own
DNA if a mutation affects mitochondrial
DNA some might be healthy
others defective and different cells can
have different numbers of defective
mitochondria inside them that means that
some cells may be less affected than
others
the diseases caused by damaged
mitochondria can also be varied they can
affect any organ or tissue and they can
appear at different times throughout
life
for example lay syndrome is the most
common type to develop in childhood
it can affect patients in a number of
ways including loss of skills epilepsy
and problems with muscle function
mutations in over 75 genes in both
nuclear and mitochondrial DNA can lead
to this syndrome so what can be done to
tackle mitochondrial diseases like lay
syndrome treating patients is difficult
but in some cases the disease can be
stopped before it's passed on
mitochondria are inherited from the
mother if the mutation is in the
mitochondrial DNA this inheritance can
be blocked one approach is to combine
the nuclear DNA from an affected egg
cell with healthy mitochondria from
another woman the embryo would then have
nuclear DNA from the original mother and
father and mitochondrial DNA from the
egg cell donor this has led some to call
such potential infants 3 parent babies
this technique is still very new but it
has recently been approved in the UK it
may be a controversial approach but
techniques like these could finally help
combat these devastating diseases
you